c
serez vous capable de vivre sans
internet
du jour au lendemain je pourrais passer
une fin de semaine où fait une semaine
sans crédits viennent de sortir des
réseaux est carrément moi
personnellement oui j'ai pas des réseaux
sociaux
donc je pas connecté tout est facile de
jouer complètement d'accord c'est le
monde dépendent juste de teint ethernet
internet internet 20 mentions ces
contrôles y corps humain vous seriez
vous capable
et si vous étiez citoyens de crayon
gouvernement décide de couper l'accès
internet qui vous parle et fait
référence est ce qui arrive de l'autre
côté de la fenêtre baissée non chose que
c'est comme couper un peu la liberté aux
gens ça me révolte aurait si un
gouvernement coupé l'accès à internet
c'est parce qu'il peut regarder leur
population tuant dans leur pays
c'est comme couper les droits des
personnes un peu ma liberté puis la
connaissance de personnes note priver de
ma liberté ce serait absolument
impossible et c'est précisément ce qui
s'est passé au cours des derniers mois
dans le cachemire un état frontalier de
la chine et du pakistan
le gouvernement central un dire couper
l'accès au web entre autres pour mieux
contrôler les volontés des dépendances
une mesure extrême qui s'est produite à
près de 60 reprise en 2019 selon un
rapport et des parents on l'a donc vu
jeff il ya des moments où des
gouvernements souvent autoritaires
charte la retirer l'une en coop internet
c'est souvent on voit là un réflexe
convoi dernière marc d'hab on l'a vu
dans plusieurs pays ont lieu dans
plusieurs pays d'afrique dernièrement le
vus au cachemire en inde
on l'a vu aussi en iran donc les
gouvernements qui coupent l'internet
voire même couple tout
télécommunications à ce point est donc
le but de ces bons points premièrement
de contrôle de l'information donc les
gens peuvent pour s'informer et peuvent
pas informé les autres noms peuvent
transmettre de l'information et aussi
bien sûr les journalistes d'autres de
plus en plus besoin d'internet pour
faire leur travail
donc en coupant internet on en peut on
isole le pays du reste de la planète
donc personne peut voir ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur et même les gens qui sont
dans territoire ondam zara s'informer
donc sapeurs trou noir qu'on crée un
vide que ces gouvernements leur créer
est-ce que ça produit les effets
escomptés
lévitte de l'information ça n'existe pas
marca qu'il ya un vide d'information
professionnelle de journalistes de
médias
les gens vont trouver des manières de
véhiculer des informations rien à tenter
par exemple exactement mon cahier un
attentat
geste naturel souvent dans les premières
minutes des premières heures on n'a pas
d'informations fiables à propos de ce
qui s'est passé est ce qu'on voit sur
des réseaux sociaux c'est que les gens
cherchent quand même à s'informer donc
se mettent à circuler toutes sortes
ouvert des informations trompeuses des
photos trompeur des défauts non suspect
des choses comme ça et c'est la même
chose qu'on a vu par exemple au
cachemire
donc les tablettes a été coupée personne
ne pouvait savoir ce qui se passe au
cachemire donc déjà en inde et au
pakistan en ont profité pour mettre de
l'avant toutes sortes d'informations
trompeuses sur ce qui se passe la borde
le pakistan qui veut démontrer qu'il ya
des dépassements au cachemire cali les
autorités indiennes torture des
journalistes par exemple y avait des
poteaux sur facebook où on veut on dire
garder un journaliste au cachemire qui
se fait torturer par les forces des
autorités indiennes
finalement c'est des photos qui avaient
été pris dans une émission de télévision
une fiction indien donc on essaie de
faire de la propagande et les gens
peuvent pas vérifié c'est vrai parce que
internet est coupé mais on le sait
l'homme l'être humain toujours très
ingénieux dans des situations adverse
comme ça je pense qu à hong kong qui
nous démontre bien même si on n'a pas
internet les gens ou trouver des façons
de communiquer ensemble et de sorgues et
par exemple par an comme on avait déjà
organisé en utilisant une fonction sur
les iphone où on peut envoyer des
fichiers aux autres sans connexion
internet c'est juste les deux téléphones
questionner qu'ensemble droit qu'on
appelle et les gens envoyaient des
affiches pour les manifestations par
ailleurs durable même si l'internet est
censuré on trouve une manière de faire
circuler des messages
il ya aussi des aussi des applications
qui existent pour téléphonie mobile où
on peut s'envoyer des textos ou des
messages sans que cela passe par les
réseaux de cellulaires ou internet c'est
juste des connexions en téléphone par
exemple dans les manifestations s'il ya
trop de gens qui sont connectés au
réseau le réseau plantons peu plus
respectés ils peuvent trouver des façons
de s'envoyer des messages même si aucune
connexion donc ça c'est impossible à
toutes fins pratiques impossible à
censurer
donc peu importe les moyens déployés par
les états les gouvernements autoritaires
la technologie étant ce qu'elle est ça
nous permet de contourner tout seul
les êtres humains sont très créatifs qui
vont trouver une manière de s'informer
peu importe la situation
autre pays même scénario le gouvernement
iranien a récemment coupé l'accès à
internet sur l'ensemble du territoire
pendant une dizaine de jours la pire
vague de répression des 40 dernières
années a suivi résultat plus de 200
mains j'en ai parlé avec la chercheure à
nier diaye elle même d'origine iranienne
le régime iranien a pris une décision
assez lot de conséquences pour la
population
on coupe internet complètement ou
presque sinon à quoi ça ressemble quand
un régime prend cette décision faut
savoir que les iraniens sont parmi les
pays les plus connectés au moyen orient
parce qu'évidemment étant donné que
vivent dans une république islamique il
ya une censure internet pour beaucoup de
ces jeunes iraniens reste vraiment un
espace où on peut avoir un débat
finalement que parfois on peut pas
malheureusement y avoir dans la société
iranienne ni à l'université ni parfois
dans une famille donc on va on va aller
chercher finalement cet espace là pour
pouvoir s'exprimer et aussi pouvoir lire
et entendre ce que les autres alors
comment ça s'est opérée ce qui s'est
produit au cours des deux semaines pour
bloquer cet accès à ce réseau c'est
vital un des premiers actes très fort du
gouvernement ça a été donc de bloquer et
en fait de couper complètement l'accès
internet en juin 2009 aussi vous
rappeler c'était les élections
présidentielles ahmadinejad avait connu
pour un second mandat
après un coup d'état vraiment à un coup
d'état ici les iraniens étaient très
très mécontents ils ont parlé de
tricherie sans parler de fraude
et c'est vrai que internet les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus dans ce contexte là
un outil en fait d'échanger informations
en partant de cette observation
évidemment le gouvernement iranien lui
qu'il est pur les leaders tant ils ont
vécu cette expérience là ils se disent
on va éviter de reproduire ce qui s'est
passé là quelques années étant donné que
les iraniens sont très très très active
sur ces réseaux là on va leur couper on
a coupé internet et pourront plus
communiquer aussi facilement les vidéos
vont moins circulé on va moins mettre
une image sur la répression aussi
difficile pour nous en tout cas pour la
diaspora les médias étrangers de savoir
exactement ce que fait le régime
comment le régime réprime et objective
parce que des nations une mission
accomplie mais je dirais que l'état peut
réussir sur du moyen terme à réduire sa
population au silence sur le moyen et
long terme je pense que ils sont
confrontés un mur parce qu'ils sont
place en présence d'une population très
jeune 75% de la population au moins de
35 ans cette jeunesse là est très au
courant des outils technologiques et un
état ne pourra pas en tout cas sûr de
manière continue et sur du long terme
à essayer de réduire cette population de
le contraindre au silence
on parle beaucoup d'internet utilisé par
la dissidence la résistance en iran mais
pour l'état aussi c'est un outil qui
peut être redoutable absolument
aujourd'hui tous les dignitaires
iraniens le ministère des affaires
étrangères le guide suprême lui-même
sont présents sur les réseaux sociaux
ils ont leur page facebook et 8 comme
d'ailleurs le président donald trump ça
permet aussi à des tas en fait de
surveiller ou de contrôler qui dit quoi
qui fait quoi
suite à des posts sur facebook ou sur
youtube
ils ont réussi en fait il était très
fier d'ailleurs il avait monté à la
terre à la télévision iranienne avait
arrêté deux jeunes donc cession d'un
logique occidentale pour parce que j'ai
fait une vidéo
ciccone connectez vous donc ça aussi
c'est une manière de si vous voulez de
semer finalement quelque part la crainte
et la peur en disant mais voilà on
arrive à contrôler dans une certaine
mesure les les voix dissidentes sur la
toile